[Music]
welcome to the top 10 stories of the
month februari might be the shortest but
that just means all the game news is
packed even tighter we comb through the
headlines so you can stay up to date on
the games you love hit that subscribe
button and we'll bring the hottest
stories right to you these are the top
10 news stories of februari number 10
Kingdom Hearts Funko pops so you take
one of the most beloved action RPGs and
combine it with one of the most popular
toy lines seems like a match made in
heaven right unfortunately the kingdom
hearts funko pop line doesn't include
the main trio of Sora Riku and Kairi but
you can grab Disney staples like mickey
donald goofy and Chip and Dale those are
hitting stores soon with smaller
keychain versions coming first we took a
look at the whole lineup at toy fair and
you can check out those galleries over
on gamespot number 9 overwatch character
teases after getting on ax and sombra
overwatch fans have been champing at the
bit for a new hero and Blizzard has
started teasing the next character first
the studio published an in character
interview with Effie an 11 year old
inventor from the fictional city of new
Bonnie Nigeria then add ice director
Jeff Kaplan showed off some concept art
featuring a giant spider robot we've
never seen before could that be one of
effie's inventions well Kaplan did say
the spider is quote not who you think it
is since then the in-game name body map
has been updated and the doom fist
gauntlet has gone missing so what's
really going on number 8 no switch
Virtual Console at launch the Nintendo
switch is about to launch you might even
have one of those fancy leaked units
already but whether you have yours now
or you have to wait until launch day you
won't be able to access the virtual
console the service won't be live on day
one the same goes for streaming video
sites like YouTube and Netflix of course
you can still buy more recent
downloadable games via the eShop and if
you want more switch coverage in the
meantime check out our in-depth live
stream on the consoles OS
number seven nes classic sales and
shortages remember how hard it was to
get your hands on an nes classic well it
still is but despite the shortages the
tiny console has managed to sell 1.5
million units now I know what you're
thinking how can the things sell so many
if I can't even find one a Nintendo
hears you president tatsumi kimishima
addressed the shortages in an earnings
call saying that some internal parts of
the nes classic take time to acquire and
that the company is working to meet the
demand so hey maybe you'll get one by
2020 number six thus nest game male
fiasco let's jump from the first
Nintendo to the Super Nintendo a
redditor by the name of you is aiming to
digitally preserve every snatch game and
others are helping out by mailing in
physical cartridges in one case a
package contained between seven and ten
thousand dollars worth of games and it
went missing that basically spelled the
end of the preservation project until
the US Postal Service caught wind of the
incident and stepped in thankfully the
package was found and forwarded on to be
you who certainly learned a valuable
lesson about shipping valuables and mail
this is exactly why we have insurance
number five God of War devs art leak we
all know Sony santa monica from the god
of war series but the team was also
working on a sci-fi game once upon a
time and we might have gotten a peek at
the cancelled project the pictures were
published by an ex-employee and you can
see them all for yourself on imager what
you'll find is a bunch of space punk
style concept art featuring pirate and
military looking characters creepy
aliens and giant monsters maybe this
would have made for a solid ps4
exclusive but for now we'll just have to
look at the space unicorns and wonder
what could have been
number four shadow of Mordor sequel do
you remember middle-earth shadow of
Mordor it was gamespot's 2014 game of
the year after all well monolith is back
at it with Middle earth shadow of war
after its existence leaked on targets
website the studio dropped an awesome
announcement trailer featuring the
return of Heroes talion and celebra more
just like shadow of Mordor shadow of war
takes place between the Hobbit and The
Lord of the Rings it's headed to ps4
xbox one and pc on august twenty seconds
in North America and August
twenty-fourth in the UK and a gameplay
trailer is coming next week number 3
PlayStation now cancellations speaking
of canceled PlayStation things PS now is
ditching every platform except ps4 and
PC so that means no more streaming on
ps3 Vita Vita TV or any smart TV running
the PS now app those will all be phased
out by August fifteenth with some TVs
losing access on April first and no this
whole thing isn't some elaborate april
fools joke number two the castlevania TV
show while we're talking about streaming
let's talk about the new castlevania
Netflix series it's being produced by
adi shankara who also produced the grey
and red he says the show is in the same
vein as Game of Thrones and that it's
based on Castlevania 3 Dracula's curse
so if it follows the game we'll see
Trevor Belmont fighting it up in 15th
century Europe alucard himself might
show up to the show is animated by
Frederator a name you might recognize
from fairly odd parents and adventure
time now just picture them doing a
bloody r-rated cartoon number one III
going public when it comes to video
games there's no event bigger than III
and if you've ever wanted to experience
it for yourself now you totally can for
the first time ever public tickets are
being sold so that anyone can make the
trek to Los Angeles for all the big
announcements early bird pricing has
ended but as of the time of this video
you can still grab full price tickets
knows maybe you'll see your favorite
gamespot people there too so those were
the biggest stories of februari quite a
lot for a short month if you want to
keep up with everything else going on
this year make sure you hit that
subscribe button in the meantime you can
stay tuned to gamespot for all the best
reviews features and gameplay
you